Let us look at analogical retrieval more closely. Once again,
we have come across this idea earlier. We did analogical retrieval in
recording cases by the k nearest neighbor method. We did analogical retrieval on
a case based reasoning using two different methods, the array method and
the discrimination tree method. Here the criteria for evaluating similarity were
very clear, as we discussed earlier. [UNKNOWN] distance, same tags,
as well as placement in this discrimination tree. The question now becomes,
what criteria should be used to decide on the similarity between the target
problem and the source case, given that they come from different domains?
On surface, there seems to be little similar between the two. None of
the objects are similar. None of the values of features are similar. Yet,
there is a deep similarity there. We can distinguish now between superficial
similarity between two situations and deep similarity between two situations.
Superficial similarity deals with features of objects or counts of objects or
objects themselves. Deep similarity deals with relationships between objects, or
sometimes relationships between relationships. Examples of this arise from
the variables test with which you are already familiar. Features here refer to
the size of the square, the size of the circle, or perhaps where there is
a hollow square, or a solid dot. The count refers to the number of squares,
or number of circles, in a particular image. Objects here refer to circles and
squares and dots. Let us look at relationship between objects.
Two situations are said to be deeply similar,
if the relationship between the objects is similar. As an example, a and
b are similar, in that, that the dot is outside the circle here and
the square is outside the circle here. A and
b are also similar in that the dot is above the circle here and the square is
above the circle here. What about relationships between relationships?
Let us compare a and b. In going from A to B, the dot has disappeared, and
a square has come outside the circle, and become bigger. Now we can compare this
relationship between a and b, with some of the relationship between a c and
a b, in which too, some object might be disappearing, and
another object which may be in the center of the circle comes out of the circle.
I'm sure you've come across problems like that on the variable test.
This is an example of a binary relationship, a relationship between two objects.
This is an example of a higher order relationship, a tertiary relationship if
you wish. This is a relationship between the relationship between objects.
You might even say that these are examples of unary relationships.
These are just examples of objects and their features and
counts. In general, as we go from unary relationships to binary relationships to
tertiary relationships to even higher order relationships, the similarity
becomes deeper and deeper. This means that mind decides two situations to
be more similar if the similarity is at the level of relationship between
objects rather simply at the level of objects or features or counts and objects.